the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or to view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
let me start by basically listing the
main things we've learned over the past
three weeks or so and I'll add a few
complements of information about that
because there's a few small details that
I didn't quite clarify and that I should
you know probably make a bit clearer
especially what happens at the very end
of yesterday's class so here's a list of
things that should be on your review
sheet for the exam so the first thing we
learned about the main topic of this
unit is about functions of several
variables so we've learned how to think
of functions of two of three variables
in terms of plotting them in particular
well not only the graph but also the
contour plot and how to read a contour
plot
and we've learned how to study
variations of these functions using
partial derivatives so remember we've
defined the partial of F with respect to
some variable say X to be the rate of
change with respect to X when we hold
all the other variables constant so if
you have a function of x and y this
symbol means you differentiate with
respect to X treating Y as a constant
and we've learned how to package partial
derivatives into a vector the gradient
vector so for example if we have a
function of three variables that's just
the vector whose components are the
partial derivatives and we've seen how
to use the gradient vector of a partial
derivatives to derive various things
such as approximation formulas so the
change in F when we change x y&z
slightly is approximately equal to well
there's several terms and I can rewrite
this in vector form as the gradient dot
product the amount by which the position
vector has changed okay so basically
what causes F to change is that I'm
changing XY and Z by small amounts and
how sensitive F is to each variable is
precisely what the partial derivatives
measure and in particular we can use so
this approximation is called the tangent
plane approximation because it tells us
in fact it amounts to identifying the
graph of a function with its tangent
plane it means that we
assume that the function depends more or
less linearly on XYZ and if we set these
things equal what we get is actually we
are replacing the function by its linear
approximation we're replacing the graph
by its tangent plane except of course we
haven't seen the graph of a function of
three variables because that would live
in four-dimensional space so when we
think of the graph it's really with a
function of two variables that also
tells us how to find tangent planes to
level surfaces so
we call that the tangent plane to a
surface given by the equation f of X Y Z
equals C at a given point can be found
by looking first for its normal vector
and we know that the normal vector is
actually well one normal vector is given
by the gradient of a function because we
know that the gradient is actually
pointing perpendicularly to the level
sets towards higher values of a function
it gives us the direction of fastest
increase of a function okay any
questions about these topics no okay so
let me add actually a cultural note to
what we've seen so far about partial
derivatives and how to use them which is
maybe something I should have mentioned
couple of weeks ago so why do we like
partial derivatives well one obvious
reason is we can do all these things but
another reason is that really you need
partial derivatives to do physics and to
do actually to understand much of the
world that's around you because a lot of
things actually are governed by what's
called partial differential equations
okay so that's if you want a cultural
remark about what this is good for so a
partial differential equation is an
equation that involves the partial
derivatives of a function so you have
some function that's unknown that
depends on a bunch of variables and a
partial differential equation is some
relation between its partial derivatives
so let me say these are equations
involving the partial derivatives of an
unknown function so let me give you an
example to say to see how that works so
for example the heat equation is one
example of a partial differential
equation
it's the equation well let me write you
write for you the space version of it in
the equation partial F partial T equals
some constant times the sum of the
second partials with respect to XY and Z
so this is an equation where we're
trying to solve for assumption F
that depends actually on four variables
X Y Z and T and what should you think of
you know what what should you have in
mind well this equation governs
temperature so if you think that f of X
Y Z T will be the temperature at a point
in space at position X Y Z and at time T
then this tells you how temperature
changes over time it tells you that at
any given point the rate of change of
temperature over time is given by this
complicated expression in the partial
derivatives in terms of the space
coordinates XYZ so if you know for
example the initial distribution of
temperature in this home and if you
assume that nothing is generating heat
or taking heat away so if you don't have
any air conditioning or heating going on
then it will tell you how the
temperature will change over time and
eventually stabilize to some final value
yes why do we take the partial
derivative twice well that's a question
I say I'd say it's a question for a
physics person but actually I'm going to
know in a few weeks will actually see a
derivation of where this equation comes
from and try to justify it but really
that's something you will see in a
physics class okay the reason for that
is basically physics of how heat is
transported between you know particles
in a fluid or actually in any medium but
this constant K actually is called the
heat conductivity it tells you how well
the heat flows for the material that
you're looking at so anyway I mean I'm
giving it to you just you know to show
you an example of a real-life problem
where in fact you have to solve one of
these things so now how to solve partial
differential equations is not a topic
for this class it's not even a topic for
1803 which is called differential
equations without partial which means
we're actually you will learn tools to
study and solve these equations but when
there's only one variable involved and
you'll see it's already quite hard and
if you want more when later on we have
many funny classes about partial
differential equations but you know one
thing at a time
so just I wanted to point out to you
that very often functions that you see
in real life
satisfy many nice relations between the
partial derivatives okay so that was you
know in case you were wondering why on
the syllabus for today it said partial
differential equations now we've
officially covered the topic that's
basically all we need to know about it
okay
but we'll get back to that a bit later
you'll see okay if there's no further
questions let me continue and go back to
my list of topics oh sorry I should have
written down but this equation is solved
by temperature at four point XY Z at
time T ok and there are actually many
other interesting partial differential
equations you will maybe sometime learn
about the wave equation that governs how
waves propagate in space about the
diffusion equation which tells you how
you know when you have maybe a mixture
of two fluids how this somehow makes
over time and so on there's basically
two every problem you might want to
consider there's a partial differential
equation to solve okay anyway sorry back
to my list of topics so one important
application we've seen of partial
derivatives is to try to optimize things
try to solve minimum maximum problems so
remember that we've introduced a notion
of critical points of a function so a
critical point is when all the partial
derivatives are zero
and then there are various kinds of
critical points there are Maxima there's
minimal but there's also saddle points
and we've seen a method using second
derivatives to decide which kind of
critical point we have so if you say
that's for a function of two variables
to try to decide whether a given
critical point is a minimum a maximum or
saddle point and we've also seen that
actually that's not enough to find the
minimum of a maximum of a function
because the minimum of a maximum could
occur on the boundary so just to give
you a small reminder when you have a
function of one variable you know if
you're trying to find the minimum and
the maximum of say a function whose
graph looks like this
well you're going to tell me quite
obviously that the maximum is this point
up here and that's a point where the
first derivative is zero that's a
critical point and we use the second
derivative to see that this critical
point is a local maximum but then when
we're looking for the minimum of a
function well it's not at a critical
point it's actually here at the boundary
of the domain of you know the range of
values that we are going to consider so
here the minimum is at the boundary and
the maximum is at a critical point
so similarly when you have a function of
several variables say of two variables
for example then the minimum and the
maximum will be achieved either at a
critical point and then we can use these
methods to find where they are or
somewhere on the boundary of the set of
values that are allowed so it could be
that you know we actually achieve a
minimum by making x and y as small as
possible maybe letting them go to zero
if they had to be positive or maybe by
making them go to infinity so we have to
keep our minds open and you know look at
various possibilities so we're going to
do a problem like that we're going to go
over the practice problem from the
practice test to clarify this so another
important cultural application of
minimum maximum problems in two
variables that we've seen in class is
the least squares method to find the
best 59 of the best fit anything really
to you know find when you have a set of
data points what's the best linear
approximation for these data points and
here I have some good news for you where
you should definitely know what this is
about it will not be on the list
okay
okay but doesn't mean that you should
forget everything we've seen about it
okay
now what's next on my list of topics so
we've seen differentials so remember the
differential of F by definition would be
this kind of quantity so at first it
looks just like a new way to package
partial derivatives together into some
new kind of object now what is this good
for well it's a good way to remember
approximation formulas it's a good way
to also study how variations in XYZ
relate to variations in F in particular
we can divide this by variations of by
actually by DX or by dy or by DZ in any
situation that we want to find a by D of
some other variable to get chain rules
so the chain rule says for example well
there's many different situations but
for example if x y&z depend and some
other variable say the variables maybe
even U and V then that means that F
becomes a function of U and V and then
we can ask ourselves how sensitive is f
to the value of U and well we can answer
that so the chain rule is something like
this and let me explain to you again
where this comes from
so basically what this quantity means is
if we change you and keep V constant
what happens to the value of F well why
would the value of F change in the first
place when F is just a function of XYZ
and not directly of you well it changes
because x y&z depend on you so first we
have to figure out how quickly XY and z
change when we change you well how
quickly we do that is precisely partial
X partial u partial Y partial u partial
Z partial u these are the rate of change
of XYZ when we change U and now when we
change x y&z that causes F to change how
much does F change
well partial F partial X tells us how
quickly F changes if I just change X so
I get this that's the change in F caused
just by the fact that exchanges when new
changes but when Y also changes Y
changes at this rate and that causes F
to change at that rate and Z changes as
well and that causes F to change at that
rate and V effects add up together does
that make sense okay
and so in particular we can use the
chain rule to do changes of variables if
we have say a function defined in terms
of polar coordinates R and theta and
we'd like to switch it to rectangular
coordinates x and y then we can use
chain rules to relate the partial
derivatives and finally last but not
least we've seen how to deal with non
independent variables so when our
variables say XYZ related by some
equation so one way we can deal with
this is to solve for one of the
variables and get go back to two
independent variables but we can't
always do that of course on the exam you
can be sure that I will make sure that
you cannot solve for the variable you
want to remove because that would be too
easy so then when we have to keep all of
them but handle you know take take into
account this relation we've seen two
useful methods one of them is to find
the minimum of a maximum of a function
when the labels are not independent and
that's the method of LaGrange
multipliers
so remember to find the minimum or
maximum of a function f subject to the
constraint G equals constant
well we've write down equations let's
say that the gradient of F is actually
proportional to the gradient of G so
there's a new variable here lambda the
multiplier and so you know for example
if FG well I guess here I had functions
of three variables so this becomes three
equations F sub X equals lambda G sub X
F sub y equals lambda G sub y and F sub
Z equals lambda G sub Z and when we plug
in the formulas for F and G well we're
left with three equations involving the
four variables X Y Z and lambda what's
wrong well we don't have actually four
independent variables we also have this
relation G equals well whatever the
constraint was relating XY and z
together so then we can try to solve
this and depending on situations it's
sometimes easy and sometimes it's very
hard or even impossible so particular on
the test I haven't decided yet but it
could well be that the problem about
LaGrange multipliers will just ask you
to write the equations not to solve them
okay so
well I don't know yet okay I'm not
promising anything but just you know
before you start solving check whether
the problem asks you to solve them on it
if it doesn't then probably you
shouldn't
what
okay so another topic that we saw just
yesterday is constraint partial
derivatives and I guess I have to
explain a little bit because my guess is
that things were not extremely clear at
the end of class yesterday so now we
have the same situation we have a
function let's say f of X Y Z where the
variables x y and z are not independent
but are constrained by some relation of
this form so some quantity involving XY
and Z is equal to maybe 0 or some other
constant and then what we want to know
is what is the rate of change of F with
respect to one of the variables say X or
Y or Z when I keep the others constant
well I can't keep all the others
constant because that wouldn't be
compatible with this with this condition
I mean that would be the usual also
called formal partial derivative of F
ignoring the constraint to take this
into account means that if we vary one
variable while keeping another one fixed
then the third one since it depends on
them must also change somehow and we
must take that into account so let's say
for example we want to find because I'm
going to do a different example from
yesterday so that if you really didn't
like that one you don't have to see it
again
so let's say that we want to find the
partial derivative of F with respect to
Z keeping Y constant so what does that
mean that means Y is constant Z that is
and X somehow is mysteriously a function
of y and z through this equation
and then of course because it depends on
Y that means X will vary sorry X depends
on Y & Z and Z values so now we are
asking ourselves what's the rate of
change of F with respect to Z in this
situation and so we have two methods to
do that so let me start with the one
with differentials which hopefully you
kind of understood yesterday but if not
here's the second options so using
differentials means that we'll try to
express DF in terms of DZ in this
particular situation okay so what do we
know about DF in general well we know
that DF is f sub X DX plus F sub y dy
plus partial F partial Z DZ
that's the general statement but of
course we're in a special case we're in
a special case where first Y is constant
Y is constant means that we can set D Y
to be zero okay so this goes away and
becomes zero the second thing is
actually we don't care about X we'd like
to get rid of X because it's this
dependent variable what we really want
to do is X plus DF only in terms of DZ
so what we need is to relate
DX with DZ well to do that we need to
look at how the variables are related so
we need to look at the constraint in G
well how do we do that we look at the
differential of G okay so DG is G sub X
DX plus G sub y dy plus G sub Z DZ and
that's 0 because we are setting G to
always stay constant G doesn't change if
G doesn't change then we have a relation
between DX dy and DZ well in fact we
said we are going to look only at the
case where Y is constant so Y doesn't
change this becomes 0 well now we have
our relation between DX and DZ we know
how X depends on Z and when we know how
X depends Z we can plug that into here
and get how f depends on Z okay let's do
that
okay so well so again saying that G
cannot change and keeping Y constant
tells us G X DX plus G Z DZ is 0 and
we'd like to solve for DX in terms of DZ
that tells us DX should be minus G Z DZ
divided by G X ok so if you want this is
the rate of change of X with respect to
Z when we keep Y constant in our new
terminal in our terminology this is
partial Z no its partial x over partial
Z with y held constant it's just the
rate of change of X with respect to Z so
now when we know that we are going to
plug that into this equation and that
will tell us that DF is f sub x times DX
well what is DX DX is now minus GZ over
GX DZ plus FZ DZ so that will be minus F
X G Z over G X plus F Z times DZ and so
this coefficient here is the rate of
change of F with respect to Z in the
situation we are considering so this
quantity is what we call partial F over
partial Z with y held constant that's
what we wanted to find ok
so now let's see another way to do the
same calculation and then you can choose
which one you prefer
so the other method is using the chain
rule okay
so let's use the chain rule to
understand how f depends on Z when Y is
held constant so let me first write the
chain rule bodily and then we'll try to
analyze what's going on so you can just
use the version that I have up there as
a template to see what's going on but
I'm going to explain it more carefully
again okay so that's the most mechanical
and no mindless way of writing down the
chain rule I'm just saying here let's
say that I'm varying the keeping Y
constant they want to know how f changes
well F might change because X might
change
white might Y might change and Z might
change now how quickly does exchange
well the rate of change of X in this
situation is partial X partial Z with y
held constant so if I change X at this
rate then F will change at that rate now
why might change so the rate of change
of Y would be the rate of change of y
respect to Z holding Y constant wait a
second if Y is held constant then why
doesn't change so actually this guy is
zero and you didn't really have to write
that term that I voted just to be
systematic okay if Y had been somehow
able to change at a certain rate then
that would have caused F to change at
that rate of course if F is held
constant so if Y is held constant then
nothing happens here and finally well Z
is changing at a certain rate this rate
is this
one and that causes I have to change at
that height and then we add VFX together
okay see it's nothing but the good old
chain rule just I've put these extra
subscripts to tell us what is held
constant and what isn't okay now of
course we can simplify it a bit more
because here how quickly does Z change
if I'm changing Z well the rate of
change of Z with respect to itself is
just 1 okay so in fact really mysterious
part of this is the one here which is
the rate of change of X with respect to
Z and to find that we have to understand
the constraint okay so how can we find
the rate of change of X with respect to
Z well we could use differentials like
we did here but we can also keep using
the chain rule
so how can I do that well I can just
look at how G would change with respect
to Z when Y is held constant so I just
do the same calculation but with G
instead of F but before I do it let's
ask ourselves first what is this equal
to
well if G is held constant then when we
very easy keeping Y constant and
changing X well G still doesn't change
its held constant so in fact that should
be zero okay but if we just say that
we're not going we're not going to get
to that so let's see how we can compute
that using the chain rule well the chain
rule tells us G changes because XY and Z
change okay how does it change because
of X well partial G partial x times the
rate of change of X how does it change
because of Y well partial G partial Y
times the rate of change of Y but of
course if you're smarter than me then
you don't need to actually write this
one because Y is held constant and then
there's the rate of change because Z
changes and how quickly Z changes here
of course is 1 okay so out of this you
get that well I'm tired of writing
partial G partial X with interest right
G sub X times partial X partial Z Y
constant plus G sub ok and now we found
how X depends on Z partial X partial Z
with y held constant is negative G sub Z
over G sub X now we plug this into that
and we get our answer
as it goes all the way up here okay and
then we get the answer I'm not going to
well I guess I can write it again
so there was partial f 4x times this guy
minus G sub Z over G sub X plus level F
about our focuses and you can observe
that this is exactly the same formula
that we had over here in fact let's
compare these two methods side-by-side I
claim with it exactly the same thing
just with different notations see if you
take the differential of F and you
divide it by DZ in this situation where
Y is held constant and so on you get
exactly this chain rule out there right
that chain hole up there is this guy DF
divided by D Z with y held constant and
the term involving you I was replaced by
zero on both sides because we knew
actually that Y is held constant now the
real difficulty in both cases comes from
DX and what we do about DX is we use the
constraint so here we use it by biking
DG equals zero here we write the chain
rule for G that's the same thing just
divided by D Z with y held constant ok
so this formula or that formula are the
same just dividing by DZ with y held
constant and then in both cases we used
by to solve for DX and then we plugged
into the formula for DF to express DF D
Z no partial F partial Z with y held
constant ok so the two methods are
pretty much the same quick ball who
prefers this one will prefer that one
okay majority vote seems to be for
differentials that doesn't mean that
it's better okay both are fine you can
use whichever one you want but you
should give both the time okay any
questions yes so I can we use
yes thank you I forgot to mention it
where did that go
I think I've erased that part so yes we
need to know directional derivatives we
pretty much the only thing to remember
about them is that the FDS in the
direction of some unit vector u is just
a gradient F dot product with u so
that's you know pretty much all we know
about them any other topics that I
forgot to list no yes is pebbles at the
time no I would need free hands to do
that
okay let's see
okay I think what we should do for is
look quickly at you know the practice
tests I mean given the time you will
mostly have to think about it yourselves
but so hopefully you have a copy of the
practice exam oh yes okay so let's look
at the second so the first problem is a
simple problem find the gradient final
approximation formula hopefully you know
how to do that the second problem is one
about weighting a contour plot and so
before I let you go for a weekend I want
to make sure that you actually know how
to read a contour plot so one thing I
should first mention is you know this
problem asks you to estimate partial
derivatives by reading a contour plot we
haven't done that so that won't be
actually on the test will be doing
qualitative questions like what is the
sine of a partial derivative is it zero
less than zero or more than zero you
don't need to bring your whole order to
estimate partial derivatives in the way
that this problem asks you to
okay I guess
so
okay so let's look at problem to be
going to be is asking you to find a
point at which H equals 2200 partial H
partial X equals 0 and partial H partial
Y is less than 0 so let's try and see
what is going on here so a point where F
equals 2200 well that should be probably
unavailable curve that is 2200 so we can
actually zoom in and here's here's the
level 2200 okay now I want partial H
partial X to be 0
that means if I change X keeping Y
constant the value of H doesn't change
so which points on the level curve
satisfy that property yeah it's the top
and the bottom okay if you are here for
example and you move in the x-direction
when you see as you get to where from
the left the height first increases and
then decreases it goes for a maximum at
that point so at that point the partial
derivative is zero with respect to X and
same here now
we also we also told and let's find
partial H partial Y less than zero so
that means if we go enough we should go
down well which one is it top or bottom
top yes here if you go no then you go
from 2200 down to 2100 so this is where
the point is so now the problem here was
also asking you to estimate partial H
partial Y and just if you're curious how
you would do that well you would try to
figure out how long it takes before you
age the next level curve okay and you
see that so here to go from here to here
so
- go on cue to this new point say cube
minor the change in Y well you'd have to
hit the scale which was up down here
okay
that would be about something like 300
what's the change in height when you go
from Q to Q prime where you go down from
2200 to 2,100 that's about well that's
actually - 100 exactly okay and so Delta
H over Delta Y is about minus one-third
well minus 100 over 300 which is whoops
getting out of minus one-third and
that's the same I mean that's an
approximation for the partial derivative
okay so that's how you would do it now
so okay let me go back to other things
so if you look at this practice exam
basically there's a bit of everything
and it's kind of know fairly
representative of what might happen
on Tuesday so you know there will be a
mix of easy problems and other problems
expect something about you know
computing radians approximation space of
change expect a problem about reading
the contour plot expect one about the
minimax problem something about Lagrange
multipliers something about the chain
rule and something about constraint
partial derivatives I mean pretty much
all the topics are going to be there